chairman for this meeting
members the set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
2nd of september 2021 in the interest of
member and officer safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you're giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak i will then invite you
at the appropriate time
please note that the
youtube live stream sound recording is
dependent on the correct use of the
microphones therefore can i
sorry that doesn't make any sense that
message that's just popped up in my chat
perhaps you might like to review that
message
um sorry members
members officers during each item please
put your hand up to indicate if you wish
to speak i will then invite invite you
at the appropriate time please note that
the youtube live stream live i can't say
live stream
live stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of the microphones
therefore can i ask that when invited to
speak you turn remember to turn your
microphone on and then turn it off when
finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind this top table
let's do that every time
okay i'm not going to read out the um
preamble but i shall return to it if i
need to during the meeting
thank you apologies for absence may i
have the apologies for absence please
thank you chairman we have received
apologies for absence from councillor
hubner councillor morley and councillor
duik
thank you very much
i'm still going to have to look at you
up there because i'm still not tall
enough to look at you down there even
with my two cushions
thank you very much um item three
minutes it is recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 14th
of october 2021
found on pages five to six are approved
as a true and accurate record
by so moved do i have a second after
that motion seeing as you were the only
person here
thank you can we agree those by sense
members
marvelous thank you very much
okay item four public participation i
can advise that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
item 5 disclosure of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regards paragraphs
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are aware reminded that they
should also they are also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the knees need
a rise during the meeting members do we
have any
that's the bill you wanted to speak
sorry chairman i'm uh i'm doing a bit of
backpedalling here i've just read it and
i'm not actually down there either as
apologizing or here but i'm sure i was
here
you weren't because it was just
councillor hubliner councillor maize and
i
so you weren't
you said i was or i wasn't you weren't
oh shut up
felt very lonely at the previous meeting
cancer lagging was in attendance if i
recall at the previous meeting
you were here just wait see he doesn't
remember either so yeah
it's just that i'm not showing as having
sent apologies
maybe you didn't
i always do
okay
um
stuart can we amend the uh minutes to
offer apologies from councillor beale
please
yes absolutely thank you thank you and i
do apologize for whizzing through the
agenda so we've backpedaled a little bit
uh we have no declarations of interest
members do we no super
okay
so
um review of recent scrutiny requests by
members so we're moving to agenda item
six review of recent scrutiny requests
by members found on pages
7-20 of the agenda
this is a report of meetings recent
meetings of the the o fear and scrutiny
working group between two meetings held
in november and december 2021 we
considered five member suggestion forms
section 3.3 of the covering report gives
a high level summary of the five items
and suggestions of the overview and
scrutiny working group
through items parks team culture and
planning enforcement
are recommended to keep a watching brief
as they are areas where work is underway
to address issues and members are
encouraged to feedback on the
information that they would like to see
by way of assurance for these
now i have
received further information that is of
concern
that suggests that things aren't
as positive as we might like them to be
still in the parks team so um
that's that's the reason why i want to
keep it keep a watching brief on it and
i will i'm not sure what the protocol is
mrs hughes whether we bring it back to
another working group meeting how do we
how do we go about that
i think at that point it's best to
define what kind of information you'd
like to see as part of the watching
brief um because we can then report the
watching brief back to a committee
meeting so the fact that we've kept the
item open um on the watch in brief we
can just define what information you'd
like to see
okay if the committee agreed to that
proposal do we agree to that
okay lovely thank you i mean i i would
like to see some
i would like to
see qualitative information around
satisfaction
and i'm going to say why
because we know and we've acknowledged
that there have been issues within the
parks team and there have been concerns
and
we've agreed um a strategy to move on we
now have a health and safety officer i'm
aware of that which is great
but
when so much has gone on and there has
been a fair amount of trauma and pain
and anger people need to talk about it
people need to discuss it before they
can move on as counselor may said that's
the basic tenet of
therapy so
one cannot just say
good evening councillor morris
which reminds me i forgot to i forgot to
ask for counsellors and descendants we
also have councillor lagan in ascendance
for the minutes
so where was i he just interrupted me a
crucial moment we were talking about
therapy we were talking about therapy we
were
no
so what i was saying was um yet people
need to have the space and opportunity
to talk about their feelings around what
has gone on and what has happened in the
past
and i am a little concerned that that is
not happening
so
that is a particular area of
that i would like to be part of the
the watching brief
is that clear mrs hughes does that make
sense
so i've got qualitative data around
satisfaction and what space uh staff are
given to discuss um previous
occurrences thank you because i am being
advised that people are being told to
draw a line under it and move on and as
i said you you cannot do that if you're
carrying
a lot of pain and anger so thank you for
that
now i've completely lost myself here we
are thank you the item learning from a
recent tribunal gives a detailed
response that was received by the
working group
as set out in appendix b pages 16 17 of
the agenda pack and we recommend this
provides assurance to the committee
there are no additional items
recommended to add to the committee work
plan
the committee are asked to review the
details and confirm assurance of the
working group process and to adopt the
recommended courses of action set out in
3.3
we've also received another member
suggestion form since this works
completed so the working group will be
meeting again shortly
and report back to the committee in due
course
yes it is
sorry until you've done that thank you
it's terribly confusing i have the chat
coming up in the corner and uh
right where my cursor needs to be okay
thank you
thank you
sorry listeners and watchers some
technical hitches
okay so where was either the um
yeah the committee the recommendations
are that the committee reviews the
detailed forms attached in appendix b
and is assured that the working group
process is happening effectively
and little two that the committee
approves the recommended courses of
action suggested by the working group
as set out in section 3.3 of the report
do i have a secondar counselor mates
members do we want to um
speak about any of these
don't anyone want to um converse on any
of these items
am i now supposed to read out the
massive report mrs hughes or can we
assume that people have read that
yeah so yeah if members are happy to
confirm um their assurance from reading
the report then that's all that we need
to do
that would be marvellous thank you can
we agree that super thank you very very
much
okay
moving on
item seven process improvement
representatives so we now move to agenda
item seven
process improvement representatives
found on pages 21-22
and i think i may defer to you mrs
hughes on this one to present the report
please thank you no problem
um good evening members
in november the performance governance
and audit committee considered a report
around the process improvement framework
this sets out how we work to improve our
customer journeys and the internal
processes as an organisation and the
links to the full reports are found in
the background papers section of this
report
we would like members to be part of the
improvement work that we do because we
know that they can bring a useful
perspective for customer um testing of
our processes
the performance governance and audit
committee appointed two member testers
and they recommended that two members
are also appointed from the overview and
scrutiny committee too
this report seeks
two nominations to be our process
improvement member testers
thank you very much um i would
desperately like to nominate myself
please so if uh i could have a second
i'll second that marvelous
advice
oh
i'll second that if you're willing to do
that can we agree that
yeah
marvelous
because i spend a lot of time
complaining about it and you have to be
part of the solution not just part of
the problem so
super okay mrs hughes i think we we have
those too
unless anybody else wanted to uh
particularly
no i didn't think so thank you
agreed marvelous
right scrutiny item
eight proposed conversion of seating
shelter at criminal park mold and into a
service kiosk
now this item was brought by councillor
lagan i'm very pleased to welcome
council lag into the meeting tonight
so
again this is hughes i'm going to bounce
it over to you to present the
republicans
no problem um so this report is an
agreed work plan item report
set out in appendix a page 25 to 28 of
your agenda pack is a full report for
the item and the item is titled
proposed conversion of a seating shelter
at promenade park into a service kiosk
and as councilor bell mentioned this was
originally proposed by councillor lagan
the item was agreed to be added to the
work plan by committee in october 2021
and the corporate governance project
officer has since conducted an
investigation to the scope that was
agreed by the committee and that is set
out in section 2.2 of the report
the findings of the report show that
officers acted within their delegated
powers and the report provides details
around the steps that were taken
and this is in section 4.4 to 4.8 of
your report
we do also have steve butcher who's
joined the meeting and he is able to
address any additional queries and
should you have them although the
information provides assurance for this
particular decision the report also
highlights a wider finding that more
could be done to improve the
transparency of delegated decisions
operationally officers are already
working on this area and an internal
process for recording decisions taken
has been put together with the aim of
publishing a quarterly list to the
website by april 2022
the recommendation is that the report
provides assurance for this particular
item and members confirm that the
questions have been addressed and that
the work plan item can be concluded
thank you
thank you so um
members do you have any questions or
comments before i um
move to council lagoon
council maze
uh yeah thank you madam chairman um my
my question actually is is around
keeping this item open uh until we've uh
moved to a point where we can actually
see that transparency and that this um
decision that was made under delegated
powers
he is always available to members at all
times i don't want this closed until
such times as that is assured if that's
okay thank you
so the recommendation for um closing the
work plan item obviously comes from uh
in section 2.2 of the report
we've gone through what the committee
originally defined
um within the work plan item and all
those questions have been addressed as
part of this report
um
the point about
publishing uh
delegated decisions is obviously just a
something that's been highlighted as
would be better practice in the future
rather than what was originally part of
the item
um but we can bring a separate report
back i'm happy to bring a separate
report back to committee and just to
highlight what we've done around
delegated decisions reporting um you
know not necessarily as part of this
work plan but just to keep you updated
on what's gone on with delegated
decisions reporting
that might be helpful would that satisfy
you councilmans
uh yeah sort of
my only concern is that we we come up
with all these things that we should be
doing we then close an item and we never
revisit it and we need to make sure as
an ongoing process that we do make that
we do actually deliver what we're
supposed to be delivering and what we
say that we are going to deliver if we
are going to you know um set something
up for for april
then we need to make sure that that
happens
um and that he doesn't just get pushed
back push back push back if that's the
target date then i really feel that we
you know as a result of this otherwise
it may not be done
can i think a good place for reporting
on that obviously we do have to do an
annual um report of the work plan of
overview and scrutiny committee
um so a good place to pick that up
and obviously when we're drafting that
annual report we could look at all the
actions that have come out of a viewing
scrutiny committee over the last year
and to what extent they've been
implemented as well
and so that that's actually part of your
um
full cycle process
that makes sense
uh yeah through you um yes i i'm happy
with that and one of the other um
recommendations
was the uh implementation of the parks
management plan
um
and i know this is referred to in other
documentation
um how are we going to pick up that
element um of this going forward
i think for an update um steve or
richard would probably be best place to
respond to that
thank you okay i'm going to go to uh
whichever of you guys would like to
respond then please thank you
good evening members yeah the prom park
management plan as you say is
outstanding so we're arranging i've
arranged for
a proposal to interrupt you as is the
riverside park management plan yeah yes
indeed three management plans uh
cemeteries riverside park and property
park obviously this one involves
promenade park so we've got a small team
been pulled together to actually put a
proposal together for the management
plans i've asked for a full sort of
specification of those management plans
and i need to know exactly how we're
going to go ahead and and deliver that
plan it may well need uh external
funding uh some funding to procure
external services to support that and
i've asked that to be set out very
clearly if necessary we will take a
report through strategy and resources
committee to seek funding for that so we
can actually deliver that management
plan on management plans but starting
with prompark
so just to clarify so we need to call
someone in to write the plan or to
deliver the plan to support writing the
plan i mean it's a wide-reaching plan
that looks at the sort of future of
promenade park or riverside park and the
cemeteries service itself um but it sets
out a number of options and it needs
some consultation on the proposals
because it covers everything from the
grounds maintenance to future buildings
and and all aspects of running the park
which will need we will it's a fairly
large piece of work so i want to be
absolutely transparent what's going to
be in that management plan so it can
deliver and satisfy the needs that we've
identified as i say if if indeed we
can't run that entirely in-house and we
do need some external funding then
that's the bid i'll be putting back
through strategy and resources committee
thank you mr holmes i would have hoped
that we would have the skill and talent
to do something like that in-house but
maybe we don't i'm i've been vote in a
minute to cancel it i've been very vocal
around my opposition to use of
consultants and i will remain
as vocal about my opposition
to the use of consultants but i will
shush now and go to counsellor mays
please
yes thank you
um
we do have the skills in-house
however
if you take those skills out of in-house
it leaves a big hole
so it's one or other the the i know from
experience that these plans are very
large and they do take a number of weeks
to complete
they are however
very important and
i think had they been in place we would
not probably be sitting here looking at
this particular item
i know that this item sits within
the central area master plan
and i think
the date is coming up for completion of
that this year
um that was actually scheduled as a
a a
a short-term project um and you've had
five years
it's still not being delivered we need
this delivered
um
i did my background on this
sorry
uh i'm just very conscious again as i
said earlier it's all very well are
sitting here and saying we need to do
this we need to do that we need to do
the other we have to do these things
deliver these things and move forward so
that we don't keep making the mistakes
that we have in the past and that this
council
is a good council
for getting things done
so i would urge you
to action that as quickly as you can
thank you thank you thank you councilman
so what we are in fact saying just to
clarify is that it is a capacity issue
and not a talent issue that makes me
feel better thank you i'm going to go to
council lagoon now and invite questions
from you please
says
thank you indeed although i'm not sure
well it might be to do everyone's here i
don't know yet um see how we go the
first and foremost i just want to thank
this committee
and officers for taking this matter on
the
the the reason why i wanted it to go to
committee
was
i didn't see that the process was
followed correctly
uh there was areas where uh
we could have done better where we could
have put the um matter on the table for
other
businesses to come in to be looked at
this is no um
absolutely no slight at all on the
successful applicant i wish them well
they'll do very very do a great job
they'll do some good stuff for the
tanners which they're already doing but
for me it's not about individuals it's
about process
so that that's why i took it to the the
committee um
the council gets a lot of
criticism always has done about brown
envelopes openness and transparency and
that's worried me because without
defying proof of those allegations
i can't sit there and say yes we should
take those forward but this didn't sit
well in that realm because it gives
people the opportunity to make those
allegations
so that's the reason why i brought it
forward
also the shelter does mean something to
the people of malden it is a public
asset
and that public assets has gone i'm
reconciled with that the process allows
that to happen um but that's that's
something that we really needed to learn
from um and another instance was when i
took some friends down the prom once
just recently to look at one of the
flower beds that was installed in 1919
that had been taken out
didn't know anything about it so
communication is an issue on that aspect
as well
when i spoke to stuart jennings the
author of the report
um
really we looked at the lack of proper
application of the council's contract
procedural rules
and no best value so best value is a big
thing are we getting value for money are
we maximizing the potential for the
assets that we've got the sustainability
of residents and that the reason i call
that is really about principles the
principles of of that contract procedure
what does that contract procedure
actually mean you know page 26 it talks
about um it's a building it's a
community asset
you know that that's what it was
um and because this has not been done
before because this as a community asset
as a shelter um was determined to to be
converted into a
in essence a retail outlet um
the information that we have within the
scheme of delegation really talks about
buildings and kiosks it doesn't really
talk about converting assets so there
was a little bit in my mind there was a
little bit of grey
but a huge element of greyness in there
um
which you can say well that was part of
the delegated powers it says buildings
but really that
that's that's very very gray and very
cloudy
um the report says
in 4.4 that it said it at this shelter
is central to antisocial behavior whilst
antisocial behaviour happened in that
shelter always has done the center for
anti-social behaviour is that the
lookout down on the sea wall
um you can go down there and be as
antisocial as you like because that's
where most of the intersocial behavior
goes on there and i've witnessed and got
dozens and dozens of photographs over
the last year of people using that
shelter for its intended purpose so it's
a sad thing that it's gone in that
respect
the other aspect that keeps on coming up
and was in the report and mr butcher and
i've had conversations about that was a
demolition of the shelter that was not
the case
the demolition of a shelter would have
had to come to planning never came to
planning maybe it was a conversation
that was had and was misinterpreted but
that wasn't the case that shelter was
not due to be demolished
i mentioned in there about consultation
with members
yes there were offers on the 14th and
19th the second informal briefings at
four o'clock are not not conducive to
members like myself who work full-time
have other council commitments work for
charity organizations
and do other other aspects including
further education though i try as a
member to do the best i can and had a
career change um specifically to become
a counselor that i could give time to by
being in the country it's not always
possible to attend all of those
briefings but it would have been good
and another learning from this is
sharing outcomes of briefings and what
agendas actually are what what do we
need to talk about so people can get
prepared
and
really it said that the
the you know if that option the option
here wasn't chosen for conversion the
the structure would have fallen into
further disrepair
uh and misuse and cost the council more
were the council's never invested in it
yeah it's not a person's fault it would
count as a corporate body but the
council's never invested in it
i think that that sentence is balderdash
and the the last thing that got me with
was really within the process there was
we we had this at planning
in june and the planning permission was
passed members passed it that was fine
but the contractual conversations about
costs etc weren't done until later on in
the year
so to me again the process allowed an
application to be made without going out
to open tender
to be transparent to be open
to give planning permission for
something that we don't really know how
much money we're going to get in
so it seems to be round about the other
way around so expressions of interest
what could we get for our our asset
could have been the way that we could
have made a decision
so we just don't know i know we're
getting a return
in my mind a small return um
and there's no cost in the renovation in
the conversion of that shelter
but you're going to look at is that best
value could have we have got more we
don't know the system allows that
um
really
there's nothing we can do about the the
permissions that have gone through
i think one of the things i've i've seen
i really quite like um was the
management 410 the escalation of the
prom management plan that mr holmes has
just spoken about
i have a
a further comment that on that is that
there is a motion um that that's been
written and has agreed to be seconded
about the scheme of delegation with some
of the the aspects of operational
management on the promenade
i'd like to see going forward member
involvement
in those operational decisions not every
tom dick and sally not everything that
they do but i'd like that to be built in
so when we come across an asset such as
this
members are heavily involved and there's
an agreement that this is the way
forward and it's open and transparent
if we'd have done that in the first
place
we could have said
well that this is the the openness that
the council works in
is transparent we're getting the best
value it would have offered other people
the opportunity to come in
and to set their stall up
and maybe even and i think the applicant
actually offered at one point to build
another shelter
as a generous as a generous um statement
to make we've never followed that up any
further
you know my mind it would have been
better for the applicant to be allowed
to build a really nice
development down on the prom and us
renovate that community asset that
actually means quite a lot
to a lot of people or did
so i appreciate that the committee i
appreciate the officer's time
my
sadness in the whole process is there
everybody knows that um but
because of the constitution and because
of the way that
um this has been allowed to fly i think
just by deceivers pants within the
delegate of powers there's nothing we
can do but we do need to to really learn
from it
analyze the decisions because we're
leaving ourselves wide open for all
those unsubstantiated claims so this
council is corrupt
so thank you
thank you i don't know if um either of
the officers would like to come back at
all on what council had said
mr butcher yeah well i'm happy to um
yeah i think
i appreciate your concerns i don't know
i mean the report and schema delegation
that we were acting within i don't think
you know we weren't undergoing a
procurement process we weren't entering
into contract negotiations this was a
lease
and a rental agreement that we were
discussing and that was the the process
that was followed and
i think the report clearly indicates
that that we acted within delegated
powers uh and there was no evidence of
wrongdoing uh i've certainly never had
my integrity uh questioned by anybody
else uh or allegations of backhanders so
that's quite disheartening to hear that
that you've heard those
um
the best value process i think it's
current mdc policy that we seek the
marketable rate so we go out there we
get evaluation and that that's the rate
that we seek
in this instance we've actually over
achieved on that
i think you mentioned that the buildings
uh is a bit of a grey area for you
so it has foundations and a roof uh
therefore for me i would want that as a
building
um and i think that's a you know falls
within the delegated uh powers of the um
uh
uh of the director of service delivery
um
yeah i i get that the uh communications
could have been better we did have a
number of ward member briefings that we
tried to put in place uh and i
appreciate that you are unable to attend
those uh we did i did make an offer uh
of a one-to-one briefing with yourself
uh and that was never followed up
um
yeah and and so
all the i've tried to make a list of
everything that you've defined
um and i'm still sort of struggling i
think that there's a number of
policies that that i try and work
towards
um i think there's uh
a council policy within the ldp for
tourism uh the council supports uh
tourism industry particularly in
relation to ensuring the viability of
towns and supports the rural economy uh
sustainable tourism and leisure
developments that benefit local
businesses communities and visitors
it supports the tourism strategy again
signed off by councillors uh with
collaboration opportunities the council
works in partnership with tourism
leisure operators business developers
and residents in malden district
visitor experience attracts new visitors
and repeat visitors
and we strengthen and add value to the
visitor and tourist experience across
the region
i think again the commercial strategy
another strategy that council has signed
up to that we adopt a commercial culture
we be open and innovative to resourceful
ideas to improve services and outcomes
um
so
it's difficult we have a schema
delegation to work with him
i have a range of strategies that i work
to try and deliver against
and
we can
if those parameters change that's fine
uh we can work with in whatever
parameters we're set
but
it's a challenge to to work within the
delegated scheme of authority
and these strategies
and then still get a level of
scrutiny um that
on this occasion i you know i fail to
see where uh some of these concerns have
come from
and that's my
personal view
thank you mr butcher i see mr holmes
wants to come in please thank you
chairman
and start by saying absolutely i
understand the concerns have been
written this evening but equally we're
trying to demonstrate that actually
we've tried to apply the rules of the
council and we don't believe we've
actually broken through those those
rules themselves um i think the
couple of points i wanted to make is
around um
the kiosk itself has been proposed in a
former shelter that shelter has sat
there for a number of years and as you
say has had a bit of a history but we've
had no other approaches but when we have
an approach from a company a local
company successful company saying we can
make something of this for you can
actually help you deliver a better
income to the council it's their idea
they've come forward with that no one
else has come forward with those ideas
it was within the delegated um powers
that we were able to do that and the
operator was actually operating on the
park in any case with a mobile unit
under a small license
um so it's not the first time somebody's
come to the council with an idea the
adventure golf was another one with a
substantial interest now because of the
value of that it absolutely came to
members but it was their idea and
members supported that idea
i struggle a little bit where if i come
to you with an idea
and i said that's a great idea now i'm
going to take that put it out to tender
because i've taken their idea their
initiative
and what we did with the larger project
was we put its members and they
recognized it was an investment and an
idea from a company and they supported
it all we've done in this case is taken
that idea
worked within the existing um
rules effectively for the delegation and
have delivered a project that brings an
income so that that's all i just wanted
to make that point it's simply us trying
to deliver against a commercial strategy
trying to resolve a a kind of what we
consider to be a long-term problem with
the actual building and and it still
will be there in a different guys um and
that really is where we came from and i
hope that just illustrates perhaps the
thinking around it thank you um
councilmemes
thank you madam chairman
i still come back to management plan
if we had a management plan in place i
think many of much of this could have
been avoided um and we'd have been much
more
i think there was um lots lots of
discussions
um going forward uh and i i hate to say
this um councillor lagan
i'd have torn it down
i appreciate that you wouldn't have done
um and i also appreciate the concerns
that you've brought which i think are
well-founded
um however
equally the the
officers have done everything within
their powers uh their delegated powers
that i can see and i i've tried very
hard to look at all of those
and work
almost backwards
and i can't see how they would have come
to any other conclusion i think the
transparency was an issue had there been
a management plan in place
i believe that this would have been
avoided and i think going forward
um the one thing we must learn is you
know what are our recommendations from
this and and the management plan has got
to be top of it
just has to be top of it and it's not
just for um prawn park um it's also for
riverside
uh and the cemeteries um
we need plans um that we can take
forward and make the best of some great
assets that we have
and we also need to encourage local
people to be coming forward and wanting
to do things in our parks our cemeteries
uh any of our open spaces um thank you
thank you
well just something small brief to add
just absolutely concur with you council
mates about the importance of the
management plan
but the other thing that i wanted to say
and this this has raised it but i had a
similar um situation and where actually
i was able to meet with mr holmes and
one of the other burnham councillors
councillor stamp about
how important some things are to the
residents to the people of the district
that officers and even other members
might not actually realize and it's very
clear how much this shelter meant to you
council again
and i've only really really i guess
understood and appreciated that when
one of burnham's most important most
valued most historical
assets
was actually
possibly questioned for the chop and i
went absolutely
ballistic but
i'll tell you later oh it was the um the
town steps the key where uh
yeah
but i think this is a communication
thing isn't it and i think this is this
is where yet plans come in that we have
to make sure that officers
and members really realize
what think what
assets mean to people on an emotional
level not just on a financial level
because that is you know that is what
what is important to residents anyway
before i start rambling i will stop now
thank you so we're moving forward i'll
just come back to you for right of reply
yeah thank you just a couple of couple
of points yeah we do have policies in
place and the uniqueness of this
situation
um you can hide that inside those
policies or you like
councilor bella said something that's
really important is
this is important it's important to me
this asset there's a lad born and bred
in morton
but the amount of people that contacted
me
is i'm elected from the residence
i don't
you know i bring the residence calls
forward
and the the plethora of people that came
in with the concern and then with the
star and the the council brown bags
backhanders i'm i've never said you've
taken
um any bribes or anything because that
certainly wasn't directed at mr butcher
but as members we get that yeah we get
that all the time as officers you have
no clue what we're going through to be
brutally honest with you yeah we might
grill officers i think i grill in a in a
a firm
but fair way where i have an expectation
to get information to be able to take
back to residence
you may have you may consider that and
you do consider that you've acted in the
scheme of delegation
i've always said the constitution of
this council needs to be looked at and
and that scheme of delegation as i said
earlier on should be looked at
what's done's done
i think we need to learn from it the
applicant
as i said i've never been about the
applicant it's been about the process
i do have a
i still have a reservation that yes
we've gone out and we've got the value
of the asset saw that in the report
if we can get more great
you know if we're looking about
commercialization commercialization by
its very definition is about making
money
so we want to make money so
we why should we should we look at other
aspects and there are clauses in this
contract as you know
um that is a very
advantageous uh contract
well done you know
but when we go out to the market again
for other assets that we're going to be
looking at i think we just need to do it
in a much more open much more
transparent way
because those things that appear to be
a smelly little shelter that smells a
wee or a crappy old flower bed or
somebody's grandfather laid those stones
in 1919
so they mean something to people
that's why it's passionate
so as far as i'm concerned what's done
i'll always be disappointed by the
methodology
as a previous officer of two local
authorities i've also been
in that situation in management position
so i understand it
i don't particularly likes what happened
but i accept it i also accepted madam
chairman when the planning
committee made the decision to to give
approval
but i still can't get my head around how
you can approve something without
looking at what the value can bring in
at the time of approval it just seems
back to front to
me thank you for letting me reply thank
you very much thank you
so um members can we now um agree that
uh the committee can conclude our work
on this item
do you have a secondary yeah can we
agree that by sense members
super thank you very much
so item nine i don't have any other
items of business that um i consider to
be urgent so
i now draw the meeting to a close at
2012.
thank you all very very much for trying
i do really appreciate that it's been
you